[Music]
thank you
I'm sorry I think
you're at the seat sorry
oh come on you've got to be kidding me
excuse me ma'am I need to sit somewhere
else we used to be married worse 19
years of my life we were only married
for five I'm counting the recovery
in four days our daughter's gonna marry
a guy she just met little Bali millions
of miles from home I just really want to
kiss you it's like I looked up for the
first time and realized everything I
ever wanted was right in front of me
she's throwing her career away just like
her mother did so I'm the only one who
can stop her she doesn't listen to him
champagne oh two please just leave the
bottle thank you
I won't let her throw her life away we
need to trick her into dumping him as
much as this will pain us both we have
to call a truce to make this work
they've been lockstep
did you make a pact to not murder each
other until you murder me first we are
here for you my love yes we're in the
last step yes
promise no mean comments pretty sure you
don't win anything for eating the whole
pig no arguing
no passive aggression what about
aggressive aggression try to keep it
snoring down I have a nasal strip it's a
mystery you're still alone
Mom Dad this is good day
you learned that to make me look bad you
don't need my help there
are you sure they're not sharks come on
don't be
okay you might be working with us
can't believe I got bit by a dolphin
when I do that with you he said Crusher
so what's the plan I say we steal the
Rings
[Music]
how they look disappointed do you think
they're wrong you're not wrong who are
we to say that Lily doesn't know what's
best for herself
[Music]
I cannot believe you what are you
talking about she found the Rings Where
in Mom's bag I knew it what
you clean up pretty good
there you go it's not for the fiend of
heart this is not his first rodeo okay
let's go let's go can we get something a
little more age-appropriate for these
two here we go which one there's only
one I see two
oh yeah
[Music]
oh no no Steph please stop doing that oh
my God
I'm praying for an asteroid
cat
[Music]
Daisy
and JoJo three women each with a
different idea about love
hey really
love me he'd wait
[Music]
but I guess if I really loved him I'd
marry him JoJo's lost her head
you think that's gonna make me marry you
do you well it's not cause I don't have
to marry an ass it's the 80s
Daisy lost her mind
[Music]
my car easy this is Serena Windsor my
sister hi and Cat just lost her heart we
talk we read we listen to Mozart
sometimes you really believe this 30
year old guy is gonna leave his wife and
live happily ever after with you you're
living in a romance novel Joe you've got
bill
you apparently got braids all I've got
is this
and these
say that word one more time and I'm
gonna scream
married
don't worry about me I'm not gonna be
slinging pizza for the rest of my life
the best pizza
Mystic Pizza
the hell do you think Leona really puts
in that pizza
it's love with the works
foreign
[Music]
Welcome to Hollywood everybody comes to
Hollywood got a dream what's your dream
when I was a little girl I would pretend
I was a princess trapped in the tower
and then this night on a white horse
would come charging up and rescue me
just tell me how to get to Beverly Hills
sure
five bucks you can't charge me for
directions I can do anything I want to
baby I am lost all right okay you've
changed for 20. for 20 I'll show you
personally
impressed you kidding me I come here all
the time
Color Me Happy there's a sofa in here
for two close your mouth dear
what is this girl does she work she's in
sales Touchstone pictures presents the
story of a date using a date is business
that led to a deal I have a business
proposition for you I'm going to be in
town until Sunday I'd like you to spend
the week with me that's becoming a dream
come true
time to shop
get rid of your gum all right I don't
believe you did that you're going to be
spending an obscene amount of money in
here
so we're gonna need a lot more help
sucking up to us because that's what we
really like sure if I may say so you're
in the right store and the right City
for that matter
there are two people who have no
business being together everybody is
trying to land him well I'm not trying
to land him I'm just using him for sex
just doing a little business company I'm
buying this week I'm getting for the
bargain price of about 1 billion a
billion dollars their folks must be
really proud everything was going their
way well done
well done
until I don't want you to go
something unexpected happened what the
hell is wrong with you this week you
fall in love with me could I not teach
you anything I'm not stupid okay I'm
I'm not in love with him they can find
you an apartment and get you a car I
want more I want the fairy tale thank
you I'm a very special woman
Touchstone pictures presents Richard
Gere so what happened after
climbed at the tower and rescued her
Julia Roberts she rescues him right back
pretty woman
and you guys go like um get a house
together buy some diamonds
[Music]
from the best-selling Thriller by John
Grisham author of the firm and the
client
from Alan Jay Bakula director of All the
President's Men and Presumed Innocent
Julia Roberts Denzel Washington
the Supreme Court of the United States
our ultimate symbol of Law and Order but
in a single night two of its justices
will be brutally assassinated
a thousand miles away in New Orleans a
lone law student has pieced together who
did the killings
and why
and created a document that has become
known in the corridors of power as the
Pelican Brief
now she has become a Target and the only
person she can trust is an investigative
journalist everyone I've told about the
previous did if this thing reaches as
deep and goes as high as we think it
does these men will do anything not to
be exposed
[Music]
Julia Roberts Denzel Washington
the Pelican Brief
[Music]
Michael and Julianne have been best
friends for years the one constant thing
in my life is that he'll always be there
but they were never more than that call
me four in the morning whatever we gotta
talk until he popped the question I
called because I met someone to someone
else well we're getting married
he was in love with me every day for
nine years me I could see why she has
known him for what five seconds I can't
lose him George I'm a busy girl I've got
four days to break up a wedding to steal
the brightest
okay
you see me girl with the diamond ring
she knows how to you know I've never had
a sister all I've heard is is Julianne
this and Julian that Michael and I were
a wrong fit right from the start I said
that too George
she's toast the only fear she really has
is you so this means that I have four
days
you my maid of honor what why not you're
practically the best man anyway I just
asked myself what would Lucy Ricardo do
in this situation who's that guy I told
him George if we're engaged why'd be
ashamed of it right something wrong it's
just a big surprise we thought you're a
[Music]
lesbians
personally I think Mr Michael's marrying
the wrong girl just tell him you love
him
I I realize this comes in a very
inopportune time marry me
moment I wake up
before you put on
dry star pictures presents I'm the bad
guy a story about finding the love of
your life do you really love him and
deciding or is it just about winning
what to do about it I trusted you just
tell me what why did you trust me no why
did you pretend to be my friend Julia
Roberts oh Dermot moroney and Cameron
Diaz
[Music]
Michael lovely together My Best Friend's
Wedding
oh that's our maid of honor
[Music]
I'm a Scott he's the most famous actress
on earth oh she's great I have loved her
I love her smile I'd say she's the most
beautiful woman on the planet will
Thacker is the least successful
shopkeeper in Notting Hill do you have
any books by Dickens or a travel book
shop we only sell travel books about the
new John Grisham Thriller
that's a novel too isn't it
they're Worlds Apart there's something
wrong with this yogurt it's mayonnaise
there we are then but only a moment away
from Destiny
[Music]
but
I don't think you'll believe who is just
in him was it someone famous
hi
[Music]
probably best not to tell anyone about
this I'll tell myself sometimes but
don't worry I won't believe it there's
this girl but you absolutely mustn't
tell anyone else okay it's not Fergie
has to spend all your money make you
suck at toes
oh my God my flatmate
[Music]
you have a stunt
could have sent back and what'd you put
on your passport profession Mel Gibson's
bottom actually Mel does his own ass
work right
Rita Hayworth used to say men went to
bed with the dream and they didn't like
it when they woke up with reality do you
feel that way
no you don't
[Music]
tomorrow there'll be pictures of you in
every newspaper from here to Timbuktu
let's stay home
anytime I've tried anything normal it's
just been a disaster from the creators
of Four Weddings and a funeral comes an
unlikely romance and as a goddess you
know what happens to Mortals you get
involved with the gods between two very
different people the fame thing isn't
really real
you know
I live in Notting Hill you live in
Beverly Hills
everyone in the world knows who you are
I'm also just a girl standing in front
of a boy asking him to love her in a
place called Notting Hill
[Music]
I wouldn't go outside why not
[Music]
foreign
you have no actual training I have kids
learned a lot right there yeah and I'm
great with people when I was first out
of high school got married and had a kid
too I'm extremely fast learner you got a
really nice office
look
[Music]
you want my number I do how about this
for number six that's how old my
daughter is eight is the age of my son
two is how many times I've been divorced
16 is the number of dollars I have in my
bank account I'm so glad we got that out
of the way because I didn't find you
attractive either
I'm smart I'm hard working and I'll do
anything and I'm not leaving here
without a job
make me pack in a law firm you may want
to rethink your wardrobe a little well
as long as I have one ass instead of two
I'll wear what I like if that's all
right with you you might want to rethink
those ties
why are there medical records and blood
samples in real estate files would you
mind if I investigate this a little
further what makes you think you can
just walk in there and find what we need
they're called boobs Ed can I just yeah
just
hexavalent chromium can be very harmful
so it kills people oh yeah you're a
lawyer hell no I hate lawyers I just
work for them we're going to have to
spend a little time filling in the holes
in your research don't talk to me like
I'm an idiot okay I think we got off on
the wrong foot here that's all you got
lady two wrong feet and ugly shoes you
gotta find a different job or a
different guy for the first time in my
life I got people respecting me please
don't ask me to give it up you're
emotional you're erratic you make this
personal and it isn't that is my work my
sweat my time away from my kids if
that's not personal I don't know what it
is we're gonna get them here but aren't
we
they're all signed every single one how
did you do this seeing as how I have no
brains or illegal expertise I just went
out there and performed 634 sexual
favors
I'm really quite tired
[Music]
20 million dollars is more money than
these people have ever dreamed of these
people don't dream about being rich they
dream about being able to watch their
kids swim in a pool without worrying
that they'll have to have a hysterectomy
at the age of 20. by the way we had that
water brought in special for you folks
every day
[Music]
you relive a long time have many friends
many experiences
you will lose
all your money don't worry you will get
it all back again and you will come back
to Bali and then I will teach you
everything I know
[Music]
when some guy who yes looks a little
like Yoda hands you a prophecy you have
to respond I get it it's your life graph
right now just like a couple of years
ago when you were completely consumed
with being the perfect wife
mom when did you accept the life you had
my baby always searching for something
your underwear my queen just folded my
delegates oh my God baby you are in so
much trouble you know people start
resembling their dogs they used to look
like Steven
Now you kind of look like David
I need to change since I was 15 I've
either been with a guy or breaking up
with a guy
I have not given myself two weeks of a
breather just to deal with myself
[Music]
you want to go away for a year I used to
have this appetite for my life and it is
just gone I want to go someplace where I
can Marvel at something
[Music]
I'm going to Italy and then I'm going to
India and I'm going to end the year in
Bali
[Music]
I'm having a relationship with my
teacher this is my no carb Left Behind
experiment
[Applause]
[Music]
if you could clear out all that space in
your mind you'd have a doorway
and you know what the universe would do
rush in everything else will take care
of itself
Once Upon a Time in an enchanted kingdom
there was a beautiful princess
with skin as white as snow and hair as
black as night her hair is not black
it's Raven and she's 18 years old and
her skin has never seen the sound so of
course it's good it's spring mirror
mirror on the wall who's the fairest of
them all
white what what Snow White a classic
tale do you want to hear it gets a new
wrinkle
they're not wrinkles they're just
crinkles banish her to the woods
is it is it just as you instructed I'm
impressed you're not as pathetic and
wimpy as I have always believed that's
the nicest thing you've ever said to me
you're invited to discover the prince is
Rich I'm going to marry him and then my
financial problems will be so an Untold
Adventure organize a ball we are going
to sweep this kid off his feet of
romance I think the Snow White's the
most beautiful woman in the whole world
agreed to disagree mystery who are you
no white no who no way power this
doesn't fit well you must have shrunk it
cinch me up
size and Magic I'll use the Love Potion
[Music]
puppy love what am I supposed to do with
a puppy you can rub my tummy
Queen is getting married take back your
kingdom I read so many stories where the
prince saves the princess it's time we
change that ending
you're with the bandits you're with the
queen should we help her
she's doing pretty good on her own you
weren't trying to stab me right now I'm
attempted to kiss you the Bandit's
leader is a she Bandits leader is Snow
White
who feels like crashing a wedding
here I was having such a good day
everyone has magic within them
definitely have a happily ever after
thing going on Mirror Mirror anyone know
how to break a spell say hello to my
little friend
experience the untold Adventures of Snow
White
what happened to the fish
[Music]
I got rid of them
just figured it was for the best I
couldn't get into it
foreign
at the homecoming transitional Support
Center
how do you feel
happy
what we're seeking here is information
Nation
what were your duties there
I don't know
you don't know
I know I'm here
I want to be in compliance with all this
compliance
have you ever forgotten something
big
you think just a place where they want
to help us out
we're here to help them
feel better to help them
we can leave whenever we want
this is about your future
think very carefully
I can take care of them if you want look
we're here to help them what did she
know
you're worried
aren't you
yes I am
foreign
[Music]